[Musique]
de bien ce qui a été le plus constructif
pour moi c'était que ça soit
il y a une personne proche de moi qui
est posée des gestes à caractère sexuel
sur moi sans mon consentement quand
j'étais plus jeune
des personnes qui ont vécu des violences
sexuelles et qui en subissent encore les
séquelles pendant trois jours j'ai quand
même fixé le mur je pouvais plus manger
je pouvais plus boire j'étais quand même
complètement en état de choc j'ai eu des
pensées aussi c'est comme suce
d'ailleurs je suis allée en centre de
crise d'autres qui se sont retrouvés
dans le rôle d'agresseur sur les listes
qui ont sorti à travers MiTo mais il y a
certains auteurs qui sortent sont
retrouvés sur ces listes là j'ai
reconnaissent parfois qu'ils ont fait
quelque chose mais ils cherchent à être
accompagnés pour bien le faire quand des
victimes et des agresseurs acceptent
volontairement de réparer les torts
accompagnés par un médiateur c'est ce
qu'on appelle la justice réparatrice on
va dire la justice réparatrice moi
j'aime bien utiliser le terme c'est fait
sur mesure car le processus varie selon
le Bureau chercher par la victime
elles ont fait un bon bout de chemin
puis pour certaines d'entre elles il y a
une clé qui leur manque pour continuer
d'aller mieux mon pack sac j'aimerais ça
que ça soit l'autre le processus ne se
termine pas forcément par une rencontre
mais lorsque c'est le cas il y a
toujours un médiateur présent pour
veiller notamment à la sécurité des
échanges le but c'est pas dire qu'on
s'en va médiation trouver des compromis
n'a pas de sens il y a pas de compromis
sur ce qui s'est passé j'ai été victime
mais comment qu'on en parle comment
qu'on nomme les choses comment qu'on
fait ce processus là on le décède
ensemble David Mathieu a fini par
rencontrer le proche qu'il a agressé
sexuellement alors qu'il était mineur
mais plusieurs séances de préparation
seul à seul avec la médiatrice ont
précédé la rencontre à trois moi je les
vécu comme quelque chose d'assez intense
donc
[Musique]
c'est réparateur mais je te dirais pas
que c'était agréable c'était pas
plaisant alors ma colère elle a eu une
place dans ce que j'ai partagé puis dans
la colère de dire
c'est ça que tu m'as fait c'est ça les
gestes que tu as posé mais après regarde
c'est ça que j'ai vécu beaucoup de
victimes d'agression sexuelle
choisissent d'une postournée vers les
tribunaux celle que nous appellerons
Carmen a aussi voulu donner une chance à
la justice réparatrice un processus
parallèle au système judiciaire criminel
je voulais pas que lui c'est sa mettons
il soit affichés comme délinquance c'est
pas ça du tout du tout pas la prison pas
qui paye pas c'est pas ça mais qui fasse
qu'il soit aidé tu sais que
qui soit accompagné aussi pour que
finalement ça se reproduise plus c'est
ça c'était quelque chose que je
recherchais il y a plein de raisons pour
lesquelles quelqu'un peut avoir fait son
parcours judiciaire régulier puis que
saisir l'acheterait pas triste soit
parce qu'effectivement les accusations
pas été retenues ou parce qu'à terme des
procédures la personne un peu être
déclarée coupable mais la justice
réparatrice n'était un peu prévue alors
actuelle pour un adulte la personne
victime peut quand même être dans une
situation voudrait discuter et qui
justice est un des rares organismes qui
se spécialise en justice réparatrice et
qui a développé une expertise pour les
cas d'agression sexuelles depuis 2017
depuis le mouvement Mitou de quelques
demandes par année on est rendu après
d'une centaine de personnes dans les
dernières années qui nous contactent en
disant est-ce que ça peut être possible
pour moi la médiation peut parfois être
faite dans le système judiciaire
criminel mais pas pour les cas
d'agression sexuelles ce qui pourrait
être appelé à changer selon cette
avocate il y a une demande à cet effet
là les victimes demandent
la préparation et le souhaite en matière
d'agression sexuelle et je vois pas
pourquoi la loi n'irait pas en ce sens
un terrain trop glissant pour cet autre
juriste il faut jamais perdre de vue
qu'on a décidé collectivement quand même
que les récents sexuelles c'était un
acte criminel si la justice réparatrice
devenait une alternative au processus
pénal il y aurait quand même un risque
non négligeable que les agresseurs se
lancent là-dedans pas pour les
meilleures raisons surtout
qu'actuellement la justice réparatrice
se fait de façon volontaire dans ces cas
précis Carmen n'a justement pas pu aller
jusqu'au bout du processus s'il veut pas
répondre répondra pas ce qui reprend
encore du pouvoir c'est ça qui s'est
passé avec moi c'est clairement pas tous
les cas qui ça paye voilà le mien est un
bon exemple faut nuancer aussi là c'est
pas la baguette magique néanmoins c'est
ce qui convenait le plus à David Mathieu
ça m'a permis de reprendre du pouvoir
l'image que moi qui fait du sens pour
moi c'est dire que j'avais une blessure
infectée
on l'a pensé je l'ai recousu je
comprends qu'est-ce qui est arrivé je
comprends comment m'en occuper puis ça
va de mieux en mieux ça me dérange de
moins en moins mais
il y a pas ça va rester là
[Musique]